ايقاف رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان في
باكستان يدخل البلاد في دوامه من الفوضى
عمليه الايقاف تمت اثناء وصول عمران خان
امام محكمه في اسلام اباد على خلفيه تهمه
فساد تقول
باكستان ايقاف اشعل اذا فتيل الاحتجاجات
في مختلف ارجاء البلاد احتجاجات واسعه
اجتاحت باكستان عقب هذا الايقاف ما دفع
قوات الشرطه الى استخدام الغاز المسيله
للدموع وخراطيم المياه لتفريق المتظاهرين
في عده مدن ابرزها
هذا ودارت صدامات بين مؤيدي عمران خان
وعناصر الشرطه امام المحكمه التي اوقف بها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات